a lot of times on this show you may have
noticed if you've checked us out over
the many years a fake character in the
audience will say hey Conan and
interrupt me then drag me into a really
weird pointless comedy sketch I mean it
happens all the time it's kind of unique
sometimes it's fun but tonight we don't
have time we got a lot to do tonight so
I just want to let everyone know I've
instructed security to make sure that no
comic characters get into the audience
tonight
in fact Billy let's just scan the
audience just absolutely make sure no
characters just regular civilians just
regular people who are hanging out
having a good time make sure that
everything's fine actually could you go
back go back
wait go back to that guy wait a minute
okay you sir you you are definitely a
character no no no I'm an old character
just a big a fan of the show no I'm
looking at you and you're you're a
character you're definitely like a
cartoonish character okay you got me
okay what are you gonna do all right
let's just keep searching just keep
looking I want to make sure that we we
identify any characters in the crowd
just look let's be careful and let's
make sure that we just have regular
people in the crowd that we are can you
go back go back go back go back right
there that guy right there
no you sir you are a character not a
character no no just a seafarin found of
late-night comedy
it's clear you're a character cuz your
mustache is falling off it's not great
I'll grant you that
okay alright let's just keep going just
check the whole audience I want to make
sure that we don't have any just sort of
fake over-the-top ridiculous okay then
go back go back right there
you you're a character you you right
they don't look around you're a
character but what I'm not a character
I'm Gwendolyn featherbottom heiress to
the fortune just stop it okay we're no
one it's stupid just stop it Paul come
over here
Paul your head of security what the hell
happened I asked to keep characters out
of the audience it's jam-packed with
characters poche seriously what is wrong
with you people for 25 years I've been
trying to do a show like anybody else
just trying to keep it real you
characters are constantly interrupting
the show taking it off the rails
why Cohen we had a nice a spice to the
show right yeah I I mean who'd expect a
sea captain in the audience it's funny
before I even say the thing and a
delightfully quaint English nanny is a
welcome addition to this sausagefest you
know fine maybe you guys do add
something he's the show and maybe I've
been kind of hard on all of you what do
you say folks should I let them stick
around and enjoy the show
fine you guys can stay
Oh actually I can't stay
yeah I got a thing yeah yeah I I'm out
of here too the the monologue was a
little rough
wasn't the monologue a little rough
people yes and I've never really been a
fan your young shoulders
oh no that's a straw
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you